ipalle depuis 2011 j'ai surtout été
conseillé de le ms en matière de
sécurité sanitaire face au risque
pandémique
mon rôle dans le cadre cosy 19 a été
beaucoup plus limité à trois niveaux le
19 janvier le directeur général m'a
demandé de présider le comité d'urgence
coe vite 19 depuis mi mars j assure le
secrétariat de la cellule que 8,19 de
l'académie nationale de médecine et du 9
avril au 5 juin
j'ai rejoint l'équipe de jean castex
ancien collègue du ministère de la santé
qui m'avait proposé de le conseiller
pour préparer la stratégie nationale de
déconfinement les grande pandémie de
peste choléra variole si la grippe ont
scandé l'histoire de l'humanité cette
liste est ajouté un nouveau virus
coronavirus en sept années 2020 ces
grandes pandémies ont quelques
caractéristiques comme une dimension
internationale provocation d'un nombre
important de décès prématurés des filles
des soins préventifs et curatifs d
organisation des activités humaines avec
un impact économique et social parfois
très grand plus de sept mois après qu
une urgence de santé publique de portée
internationale et a été déclaré par le
ms l'actuelle pandémie ne déroge pas à
ses aspects communs tous les pays sont
touchés 30 millions de cadres est censé
près d'un million de décès prématuré à
ce jour ni vaccin ni traitement efficace
en dehors de la dexaméthasone dans
certaines formes sévères un effondrement
économique que je ne détaillerai pas
s'agissant de politiques publiques face
aux grandes pandémies il faut distinguer
la réponse et la préparation de la
réponse
lorsqu une urgence de santé publique de
portée internationale a été déclarée par
l' oms le 30 janvier les pouvoirs
publics en france aux biens a été forcé
de réagir en concevant adoptants et
mettaient en oeuvre des politiques
publiques de réponse aux risques
pandémiques je n'entrerai pas dans la
réponse mise en oeuvre pour trois
raisons premièrement le comité d'urgence
de l'oms a pour fonction essentielle de
répondre à la question du directeur
général
s'agit-il d'une urgence de santé
publique de portée internationale et de
formuler des recommandations pour l' oms
et les 195 états membres mais chaque
état reste souverain et mène la
politique qu'il entend le rôle d'
expertise de l'académie nationale de
médecine nucléaire
bien sûr les pouvoirs publics mais
malgré tout la politique publique de
réponse est en france scientifiquement
appuyé avant tout sur l'organisme des
expertises dans l'évolution du risque
santé publique france et sur l'organisme
d'expertisés en gestion du risque et le
haut conseil de santé publique
enfin mon rôle de conseiller du
gouvernement français s'est limitée à la
période que j'ai évoquées de mission de
jean castex
je vais me concentrer surtout sur
l'autre aspect de la politique publique
en matière de grandes pandémies qui est
celui de la préparation entre 2005 et
2009 je me suis trouvé en responsabilité
dans un pays qui à l'initiative du
président de la république et du
gouvernement d'alors avait décidé de se
préparer aux grandes pandémies en
l'occurrence dus au virus qui menaçait
et virus grippal h5n1 je crois que c'est
important de rappeler ce qui a été fait
à ce moment là pour se préparer parce
que malgré tout toute la question est là
en tant que directeur général de la
santé j'ai agi pour la préparation du
secteur santé création d'un centre
opérationnel de régulation de réponse
aux urgences sanitaires au ministère de
la santé création d'un établissement
dédié pour les stocks de produits la
réserve sanitaire l'eprus création d'une
réserve sanitaire création d'un stock de
masques 1,7 milliard début 2009 et de
médicaments antiviraux anticipation de
la création de vaccins suivi de la mise
en oeuvre des plans blancs pour les
afflux de patients à l'hôpital crée plan
blanc qui avait été créée à l'été 2004
dans le même temps et c'est peut-être le
plus important en tant que déléguée
interministérielle placée au 1er mai du
premier ministre j'ai été chargé de
coordonner la préparation à une pandémie
grippale avec une petite équipe
inter-ministérielle un peu dans le style
de la mission au castex toutes
proportions gardées contribution à
l'évolution de la planification porté
par le sgdn et à son évaluation par
l'assemblée nationale et le niveau
européen
contribution à l'organisation et au
suivi de multiples exercices locaux
régionaux thématiques et contribution à
l'organisation d'un exercice national
annuel pandémie permettant de faire
évoluer le plan entre 2006 et 2009
notamment sous l'angle de la gestion de
crise de l'articulation excellent
expertise scientifique et de la
communication de crise contribution à
l'organisation de l'exercice européen
euro grippe en novembre 2008 lors de la
présidence française de l'ue
euh préparation des plans de continuité
d'activité en situation de pandémie dans
les secteurs public et privé à travers
la mobilisation des différents
ministères et contacts répétés avec les
représentants de ces sectes
participation enfin à la création en
2005 et 2006 d'une industrie de
production de masques ffp2 en france
j'ai évoqué cette activité de
préparation dans un ouvrage de 2014 que
j'offre généreusement dans j'offre un
exemplaire j'ai quelques uns vendu à la
commission denquête il pourrait vous
pourrez vous reporter à partir de la
page 123 et suivantes sur le sujet de la
préparation à la pandémie
si j'ai évoqué cette importante
politique publique de préparation à une
pandémie grippale
c'est qu'elle a ensuite été critiquée
puis abandonnée et que le constat d'un
préparation aux faits en février 2020
est une conséquence de cet enchaînement
malheureux en avril 2009 une pandémie
grippale est bien sûr revenu mais pas
exactement celle que l'on attendait un
virus h1n1 et non h5n1 qui a réclamé
d'adapter la stratégie vaccinale et
surtout une gravité un peu moins forte
que celle que l'on redoutait le résultat
de cette pandémie h1n1 et que la
préparation au risque pandémique a été
critiquée comme ayant été trop
dispendieuse
il me semble qu'après 2011 l'ambition de
préparation interministériel d'ensemble
au risque pandémique a été en fait plus
ou moins abandonnée dans notre pays
selon moi pour des raisons à la fois
politique et financier la politique car
le gouvernement qui l'avait mis en place
entre 2005 et 2011 a été remplacée en
2012 par un autre gouvernement dont
certains membres avaient justement
critiqué cette préparation
monsieur milan n'étant pas là je ne lui
rappellerait pas puisqu'il avait été
rapporteur de la commission des enquêtes
du sénat en 2010 que l'initiative du
sénateur autain
par ailleurs médecin paix à son âme et
qui accuser ni plus ni moins la ministre
bachelot et moi même d'avoir été roulé
sinon corrompu par l'industrie des
vaccins soupçonné d'avoir inventé la
pandémie à shine raisons financières
enfin puisque nous un avion trophée
entre 2005 et 2009
il fallait cesser d'investir dans la
préparation la planification
interministérielle a été à mon avis
stopper les prusse a été inclus
on pas dire d'issoudun santé publique
france l'exemple le plus frappant
concerne toutefois le stock de masques
qui s'est évaporé au fil des années au
point un vraisemblable que la france
s'est trouvée en février 2020 en
situation de pénurie de masques un
espoir pour conclure que l'impact
sanitaire social économique de la
pandémie kovy 19 laisse de telles traces
que l'on prenne enfin au sérieux
dans la longue durée la préparation au
risque pandémique il faut en effet se
concentrer sans faiblir sur les risques
avérés douloureusement éprouvé en france
depuis des siècles et qui sont les plus
lourds la guerre est l'épidémie
sachons trier entre ce qui est
prioritaire et ce qui l'est moins
ne laissons pas des événements
intercurrente même s'ils sont importants
et réclament une réponse adaptée
détourner des grandes priorités de
préparation que vu leur impact potentiel
sont les préparations risques de guerres
et de pandémie pour le risque de guerre
nous avons une armée je ne développerai
pas ça devrait être pareil pour le
risque pandémique
tout incite à se préparer je conclurai
par quelques suggestions pour le
législateur une obligation de
préparation au risque pandémique une
planification interministériel
régulièrement mise à jour déclinés
tester et évaluer une coordination
interministérielle pour la mise en
oeuvre de cette préparation des
contre-mesures sous la responsabilité de
l'état avec un contrôle parlementaire et
une gestion par un eprus redevenu
visible des stocks de produits de la
réserve un effort européen pour kuhn
europe de la sécurité sanitaire secret
ou se renforcent dont le volet de
préparation au risque pandémique serait
le pivot une stratégie de recherche et
développement sous le contrôle de l'opex
et une ré l'anticipation de la mise en
oeuvre des essais cliniques que j'aurais
bien conclut sur les problèmes de la
recherche en france
mais je ne veux pas dépasser mon temps
et je m'arrête ici je vous remercie de
votre attention
merci mais votre temps est dépassé c'est
ce n'est pas grave
merci professeur jean-yves grall
à vous la parole mais dans cinq dix
minutes
merci monsieur le président merci le
rapporte me rapporte mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
mon propos sera plus plus court je pense
pour vous signaler donc effectivement je
suis directeur général de la santé la
suite de didier houssin de mai 2000
à 30 septembre 2013 venant de l' agence
régionale de santé de lorraine et
retournant par la suite à l' agence
régionale de santé de nord pas de calais
et je suis actuellement directeur
général de l'agencé régionale de santé
auvergne rhône-alpes depuis le 1er
novembre 2016 sur l'ensemble de ces
éléments
mon passage comme directeur général de
la santé a permis d'évoquer deux grandes
deux grands thèmes durant ces deux ans
et demi passés à la dgs tout d'abord les
suites de l'est de l'épidémie h1n1 comme
l'a dit didier houssin avec un travail
sur la doctrine d'utilisation des
masques avec notamment le rapport du
haut conseil de la santé publique en en
novembre 2011 et le travail sur la
répartition des stocks stratégiques et
bien évidemment tout ceci dans un
contexte comme l'a dit didier houssin
budgétaire avec l'eprus deuxième
deuxième thème qui m'a occupé durant ces
deux ans et demi sur ceux sur la
sécurité sanitaire c'est organisation de
la réponse de l'état avec en particulier
une instruction ministérielle pour
prendre acte de l'arrivée des ars dans
le paysage le 2 novembre 2011
une circulaire interministérielle en
août 2013 concernant les modalités de
répartition des stocks stratégiques sur
le pays entre un stock central et des
stocks sur les zones de défense et entre
les deux bien sûr le plan pandémie
grippale de novembre 2011 et mis en
place pas sous l'égide du gsm à l'époque
depuis lors je suis donc directeur
général de l'agencé régionale de santé
bien évidemment je répondrais aussi à
vos questions comme vous l'aviez demandé
sur ce thème là pour la gestion de la
crise qu vide qui a commencé en novembre
ronald par le premier cluster le 7
février 2020 et depuis lors nous avons
bien sûr mis en place l'ensemble des
dispositions pour arriver maintenant
avec deux phases une première fois
jusqu'au confinement et une deuxième
phase actuellement en phase de
développement malheureusement avec
notamment les problèmes de
d'hospitalisation réanimation et en
hospitalisation général qui vont en
s'accentuant
voilà monsieur le président les quelques
mots liminaire que je souhaitais
apporter
merci une petite précision dans les
halls organisation de la réponse de
l'état vous avez donné deux dates et je
n'en n'est peut-être qu'une vous m'en
excuser en interministériel j'ai noté ou
2013 modalités de répartition les stocks
voyez la fois un stock central et un
stock en zone défense mais avant vous
aviez principes chers ministres lui
souhaiter la date instruction
interministérielle pardon de 2,2 à
bertrand de l'époque du 2 novembre 2011
2 novembre 2011 c'est l instruction
ministérielle sur quoi sur l'adaptation
suite à l'arrivée des ars dans le
paysage qui datait de mi 2010 de
l'organisation sur le territoire avec
bien évidemment le rôle des uns et des
autres et notamment avec les les zones
de défense et puis l'organisation à
l'inscription des ars ont lieu et place
des services de l'état s qualité de
l'époque
voilà donc ces deux circulaires nous les
avons où vous nous les transmettre par
écrit merci nature alors professeur
valais c'est à vous merci et merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs le rapporteur mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs
donc effectivement je m'appelle benoît
bellaiche
je suis médecin j'ai été anesthésistes
réanimateurs puis directeur général de
la santé donc de 23 octobre 2013 au 8
janvier 2018 donc tout début de l'année
2018 ce qui m'a permis de travailler
avec deux ministres qui ont été pour moi
marisol touraine jusqu'à au mois de mai
2017 et ensuite même busin jusqu'en
janvier 2018
je reviendrai sur ces périodes avec ses
deux ministres juste pour dire que j'ai
vécu la crise qu vie de deux façons une
première en étant missionné par martin
hirsch le directeur général de
l'assistance publique pour faire une
mission dans le grand est
au moment où la vague qu'ovide commencé
à déferler sur notre pays donc c'est une
mission que j'ai fait le 18 mars les 18
et 19 mars et qui a permis d'aider à la
préparation du système hospitalier de
paris et par extension avec des liens
avec l'île de france s'en est ensuite
comme mon collègue didier houssin j'ai
effectivement rejoint la mission castex
sur le déconfinement donc du 9 avril au
5 juin
pour ce qui me concerne le 2 juin mais
c'est avec didier que nous avons côtoyé
jean castex sur les questions de
doctrine sanitaires et donc pour avoir
des échanges avec l'organisation d'
expertise de l'époque et la préparation
donc des politiques publiques des
différents ministères impliqués sur le
sujet avec madame touraine avec un butin
j'ai vécu de nombreuses crises
sanitaires
on rappellera simplement des maladies
infectieuses émergentes
le chikungunya la fièvre hémorragique
ebola en 2014 le 10k en 2016
de nombreux événements saisonniers
hivernaux des vagues de chaleur des
actes terroristes massifs avec des
afflux de victimes janvier 2015 13
novembre 2015
14 juillet 2016 chacun remettra les
lieux au date qui convienne et avec
madame d'uzein donc les cyclones irma et
maria où je me suis déplacé pendant dix
jours sur les îles du nord dans les
suites de sept de ces ouragans pour
aider à la réparation
de ce qui avait été dégradée sur le site
et donc avec des menaces de santé
publique qui est évidemment assez
conséquente
j'ai vécu des crises sanitaires de moins
grande envergure comme la crise lactalis
qui est une crise sur la sécurité
alimentaire mais qui est très
enseignante en réalité ces épisodes ont
toujours nourri des améliorations du
système de prévention et de préparation
aux crises comme didier houssin a
indiqué très clairement dans les suites
des deux circulaires mentionné par jean
yves grall qui était mon prédécesseur
immédiat de 2011 et 2013 sur
l'organisation des stocks date est
tactique et stratégique et leur
distribution l'organisation de
distribution nous avons mis en place le
dispositif dit orsan qui est le système
de préparation et de réponse aux crises
qui a été lancé dès 2014 sous une forme
préliminaire et qui nous a permis
effectivement de répondre à la crise
ebola à l'époque et qui a ensuite été
confirmée dans la loi telle que madame
touraine l'indiqué ce matin d'autres
éléments ont eu pour origine ces
situations sanitaires et se sont
retrouvés dans une amélioration de nos
dispositions notamment législatives la
nouvelle agence de santé publique dont
il a été trés question ce matin avec son
programme d'organisation de l'eprus et
une partie de mon travail aura été pour
l'épreuve la construction de la plate
forme de vitry et donc l'organisation du
stock stratégique national ainsi que son
organisation avec les plateformes zonal
dont on parle beaucoup moins
et puis bien sûr l'organisation du
comité d'animation du système d'agencé
avec son volet sanitaire de sécurité
sanitaire qui est un dispositif
important et la réforme des vigilances
qui avait été initié par mon
prédécesseur jean yves grall on voit que
par ses éléments à la fois historique et
d'éléments de construction du paysage
législatif la continuité entre nos trois
participations à l'état est assez
évidente et donc ses politiques
publiques mènent souvent mettent souvent
beaucoup de temps à se réaliser et on
essaye effectivement la lueur des crises
de pour ce qui concerne le sujet de la
sécurité sanitaire à des améliorations
tout à fait progressive
et nul doute que de ce que nous aurons
vécu avec la crise qu vite sortir à des
améliorations en particulier pour le
paysage de santé publique qui voit là je
suis bien sûr à votre disposition dès
maintenant pour toutes les questions
merci effectivement c'est ce que nous
recherchons ses capacités d'adaptation
en tirant bien sûr expérience de ce que
l'on a connu tout récemment une petite
question très simple vitryat s'en était
prise je reconnais c'est mon département
le département de la marne vitry le
françois il y en a combien en france
donc en fait il ya la plateforme
centrale qui est à vitry et il ya cette
plateforme zonal plus à des plateformes
outre-mer et donc on a 7 et une 8 + 4
égale 12
merci en fait on les mentionne rarement
avéré c'est pour ça que c'est dans un
rôle très important dans le circuit de
distribution
tout à fait elles sont pas suffisamment
connus même par les locaux merci
catherine des noms j'avais dit excusez
moi catherine on commencerait par sylvie
vermeillet nous changeons l'ordre de
nous rapportent leurs régulièrement
merci ses résidents merci merci
nos trois intervenants je remercie
particulièrement le professeur didier
houssin pour la carte et la sincérité de
ses propos
j'aurai des questions peut-être plus
plus directement au professeur benoît
valais j'aimerais professeur que vous
nous indiquiez le niveau du stock de
masques à votre arrivée à votre départ
et que vous nous expliquer ce qui s'est
passé et pourquoi le stockage à évoluer
de cette manière
ensuite le professeur houssin a parlé
assez longuement de la préparation à la
réponse de l'importance de la
préparation à la réponse et vous
professeur vallée vous expliquez que
vous avez vécu plusieurs crises alors de
d'intensités différentes
vous dites que c'est toutes ces crises
différentes ont toujours nourri la
préparation
des crises suivantes même si ce matin
roselyne bachelot nous disait qu'il
fallait toujours se méfier des
enseignements de la crise précédente
parce que la suivante n'était forcément
pas la même mais en tout cas
effectivement je pense que l'expérience
de ces différentes crises peut nourrir
la préparation des suivantes vous nous
avez dit également professeur valait que
donc vous aviez vous étiez pencher sur
la question de la gestion des stocks le
système hors sol alors selon vous
comment est-ce que vous expliquer qu'on
était aussi peu préparée et pourquoi
malgré des alertes ac qui sont survenus
dès le mois de janvier qui était assez
précoce pour ce quoi est ce qu'on met
autant de temps à réagir alors bien
entendu vous allez nous expliquer et on
le sait tous qu'on n'avait pas de masque
qu'on n'avait pas d'équipements de
protection individuelle pourquoi est-ce
que du coup malgré toutes ces
expériences on arrive aussi peu préparée
on met autant de temps à réagir au
déclenchement de la crise voilà et puis
peut-être une autre question dans dans
le dans la ensuite dans la réactivité la
crise l1 pourquoi est ce que malgré le
fait qu'on n'ait pas de de stocks de
masques et puis que malgré les commandes
il met du temps à venir
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'est pas capable
de s'inspirer des expériences des pays
qui nous entourent pour un peu mieux
réagir je pense par exemple au masque en
tissu enfin pouvoir protéger la
population même si ce sont pas des
masques chirurgicaux
pourquoi quelque part on se
j'ai envie de vous dire qu'on n'a pas eu
plus de de réaction de bon sens
malgré tout les planifications que vous
nous avez expliqué merci la question
s'adresse principalement aux professeurs
vallée merci beaucoup madame la
rapporteure donc plusieurs plusieurs
éléments de questions tout d'abord
l'état des stocks à mon arrivée puis à
mon départ est donc je vais commencer
par celle ci donc en réalité quand je
suis arrivé les stocks étaient à 616
millions de masques chirurgicaux adultes
donc en 2013 au 31 décembre 2013 suis
arrivé à la fin octobre
et quand je suis parti les stocks
étaient au 31 décembre 2010 est je vous
rappelle je suis parti le 8 janvier il
était à 714 millions donc on a eu une
croissance de 100 millions jeu je
détaillerai après la question des
péremption et des noms péremption une
croissance de 100 millions d'ailleurs
dont le bon de commande avait été fait
par jean yves grall et donc nous avons
assuré le la fois le financement et
l'approvisionnement
sur trois années successives des 100
millions de masques commandés par le
procès par jean yves grall j'ai commandé
moi personnellement 40 millions de
masques pédiatrique et donc le stock est
remonté à 40 millions après avoir
descendu puisqu'il était à 113 millions
à mon arrivée et donc pour les masques
pédiatrique la notion de péremption
s'adapter et donc les masques ont été au
fur et à mesure éliminé puis racheté le
point évidemment le plus important en
diminution aura été celui des masques
ffp2 donc ils sont passés de 380
millions de masques à zéro au 31
décembre 2007
et je vais expliquer la raison pour
laquelle nous étions dans cette logique
et pourquoi c'est ce stock a évolué sur
le plan donc des masques chirurgicaux
adulte je vais me concentrer sur ce
chiffre
on a depuis 2009 où ces masques étaient
à 796 millions jusqu'à 2017 fin 2017 714
millions une stabilité complète du stock
et on est dans une logique qui est celle
de maintenir ce stock de façon tout à
fait évidente
un chiffre important ce chiffre
important est nourri par des éléments de
langage qui ont été fournies à la fois
par xavier bertrand
et par didier houssin dans des
présentations relative au plan pandémie
ils ont été ensuite repris par une
expertise beaucoup plus récente qui a
été délivré en 2019
officiellement mais remise au directeur
de la santé en 2018 et qui suivait une
demande qui était la mienne qui était
d'avoir un état des lieux des
contre-mesures ce n'était pas que le
masque mais c'était tout les
contre-mesures en période pandémique et
donc le chiffre a été réaffirmée par les
experts autour du professeur jean paul
stahl pour indiquer que le milliard
restait un objectif à concevoir
entendant madame chen hier et donc la
reconstruction de stoke 1 1 milliard on
peut imaginer que ce chiffre a gardé une
valeur très forte à l'intérieur de ces
714 millions de masques chirurgicaux
adultes il y avait 6 116 millions de
masques sans date de péremption qui date
des années 2006 et pas 2000 comme j'ai
entendu 2006 à 2016 puisque nous avons
commencé à demander une expertise sur la
qualité de ces masques à la fin de
l'année 2016 je vais revenir là dessus
mais 2006 2016 ça fait déjà 10 ans
peut-être ce n'est pas la peine d'en
rajouter 10 de plus et donc il faut
garder à l'esprit que ces masses en
péremption date est effectivement pour
les plus anciens de 2006 il était
d'ailleurs répartis sur différentes
plateformes qui étaient dispersés au
niveau national et qui ont demandé de
notre part un effort de restructuration
et de recentrage ces masques étaient dix
ans péremption puisqu'à l'époque les
d'ailleurs ça a été un point très
remarquable sur lequel avait insisté le
professeur houssin puisqu'en à l'époque
les industriels ne mettait pas de date
de péremption sur les masses considérant
qu'ils ne se dégradent est pas à la
différence extrêmement significative des
masques ffp2 qui comporte un module
électrostatiques et donc ce module
électrostatique a pour objectif de
s'intéresser aux aérosols et donc est
capable de capter des particules
beaucoup plus petite que les 0,3 à 3
microns classique des masques
chirurgicaux anti projections
donc c'est ma sont appelés appareil
respiratoire c'est masques ffp2 était
considéré comme se dégradant très
rapidement et surtout et c'est pour
expliquer l'évolution de ce stock et
surtout suite aux retours d'expérience
peut-être ne faut-il pas à prendre les
retours d'expérience mais tirer de là
l'événement a h1n1 ou ses masques
avaient été distribués à plus de 100
millions en quantité avec plus de 48
millions qui avaient été restitués